- My next guests have released
one of the hottest albums
of the summer.
They're a really, truly talented duo.
It's called "Ungodly Hour"
and it's getting rave reviews.
They're signed to their
mentor, Beyonce's, label.
Not too shabby.
Give it up for sisters Chloe and Halle.
- Hi!
- How are you?
- I am so good.
I know we've never officially met
but we have been on a song together.
- Yeah (laughs).
- "This Is For My Girls"
which was organized by Michelle Obama
to raise money for girls' education.
It was such a cool thing and
honestly that's the first
time I'd heard of y'all
and I was like, who are these
chicks singing right here?
And you're so young!
You're so talented.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
We're such huge fans of you
so thanks
- Oh!
- for having me on today.
- Well that is awesome.
No, I went down the rabbit hole
of YouTube videos with y'all last night.
I love your songs, love your music.
I love that it's like, bringing back
what real R&B sounds like
from whenever I was in junior high.
That's one of my favorite
parts of your sound.
Is it kind of cool though,
speaking to Michelle Obama.
You know we all got to do that together
but she's been a big supporter of y'alls.
- She really has.
- Yeah.
- And every time, we pinch ourselves
because, as you know,
she is as much of goddess
as the world thinks she is so
I love Mrs Obama.
- That's just cool though,
that she's seeing you.
That must feel really cool,
to be seen by someone
like that is awesome.
But speaking of powerful women,
you're also signed to Beyonce's label.
My fellow Texas girl, I love her.
So I understand,
she had no notes when
she heard your new album.
Did that surprise you?
Because I feel like she's kind of
like me or all Texas women,
like, let's do it right
let's get it done right and
she might be particular.
- Yes, absolutely.
I mean, on our prior projects
there would definitely be more notes
because she's an amazing perfectionist
and we love that and admire
that about her you know.
She's always been one of
our biggest inspirations
so when we presented this album to her
it was very little and minor things
and we were like, wow,
she must really like it.
So we were very, very happy about that.
- Well you both, you pushed
the release of your new album
to honor George Floyd.
How are you interpreting
this moment in our country?
'Cause you're of the younger generation
and you're very powerful
and I think we've all been
really impressed with how
the younger generation
is handling all of this.
How have you specifically
been handling it?
- Thank you, yes.
Well, the first couple of weeks
when everything was
happening we were definitely
just very sad and I feel like collectively
in our community of our
black brothers and sisters
it's like this collective
feeling of trauma
when something like that happens because
for me personally, I think
of my little brother,
we think of our dad.
That could have been them.
So we just are trying to
do everything that we can
to continue to lift each
other up with our voices
and demand justice for what's right.
I mean, our color of our skin
should not be a death sentence.
People deserve to live a
beautiful and long life
just like everyone else, so.
- Exactly, yeah.
- I mean, it's crazy that's not a given.
It's insane to me.
Well Halle, you're set to play Ariel
in the live action "Little Mermaid"
which I'm super stoked about.
That was one of my
favorites from childhood.
So, what are you excited for
fans to see when it comes out?
- Oh I'm just excited for
everyone to see the kind of
upgraded but also still very close to home
as the original I mean.
The original was my favorite
when I was little as well.
I think everybody really
connects with Ariel in a way
and resonates with the feeling
of wanting to be somewhere
and feel like home is another place
so we are really excited for it
and I just feel very
honored to take on that role
to show other black girls that
they can be princesses too.
- Yeah, representation.
Agreed, agreed.
I wanna compliment you on something too.
Like watching you,
you both have such
different energies and vibes
and they both collide in
such a cool way that is so
meaningful and I think it has to happen
in order for a duo to actually work
and it's very inspiring
to watch both of you.
You're both so captivating
in completely different ways
vocally, aesthetically, how
you move with your body,
like everything is so different
and yet it's like one unit
and really, it's impressive.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
That is so much
coming from you.
- Yeah.
- Oh well, it's incredible
to watch you, it's awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us ladies
and everyone be sure to
check out their album
"Ungodly Hour" right now.
You're gonna want to get it.